I mean a reminder Specter come from a
small town and you know running like
your dad's company coming into your
dad's company what was the creativity
that you brought to the table and such a
young person coming in like you know
it's pretty policy to come in and just
turn around a couple year to put your
efforts in and make it from a
three-million-dollar so 30 min ago okay
kind of remember like you know I think
people gloss over the stories even
though they know them like when you're
speaking three to four thousand dollars
a weekend you know out of all injuries
on baseball cards you know business like
I looked in there like what like I'm
about like I walked in there with
straight roboto like I know how to sell
it was just very easy for me I just
asked pubs I was there since I was 14
every weekend and every summer vacation
so I didn't just waltz in 22 after party
for four years the school I'm like all
right what do we do here like who was in
I worked the floor my dad's liquor store
for 12 and 14 hours a day for thousands
of days before I ever ran the operations
and spoke to actual customers that
actually bought things and ask them so
many questions could you imagine me and
16 you meant to welcome to a liquor
store and seeing the 16 year old me
don't even look at me because I'm asking
you 87 questions are trying to sell you
stuff Frank so I built up so much
knowledge that you know I walked in
there with context too many people in
this room and when I'm in this room I
mean the world jump in the businesses
that they know nothing about bout if you
let's start a startup yo let's start a
music start-up because I listen to music
are you at the [ __ ] you're going into
the music business not listening to
[ __ ] ASAP rocky you did you know so so
I think that we need to we need to start
being smart about those decisions I
think too many people are jumping in too
fast too many people are starting
companies without knowing the space the
hurdles and they get caught and they get
in trouble now they get great learning
says very honestly if you're between 21
and 20
728 I don't know what the right number
is be risky as hell make a ton of
mistakes it is the time it's perfect
sleep in a little pot for dudes do it
like all in like go really wrong as the
learnings are tremendous on the flip
side you could also go work for some
place that you actually a passionate
about that industry for a year or two
and learn a lot and be in a much better
position to succeed so the 90 the day in
the market is enormous many people make
my stories flyover than how I came in
and blew it up so fast I was ready I was
a loaded gun I knew everything about
everything like I went up to mouth day
to college in Boston I was a ship's dude
I never what the class once you know I
was doing I mean driving around Boston
going to cappys gonna Marty's go into
all these plea in school like I was like
you want you over the party didn't know
I'm go to some random liquor store two
hours away walk around for two hours
that's who I was I put in the work you
know I don't know if Malcolm Gladwell's
right about 10,000 hours and all that
stuff I did it I knew everything I
walked in 22 with the knowledge of a 55
year old so it was easy and so I don't
think we're playing in enough work peeps
three TechCrunch and think they know
something